sí Bueno gracias por la invitación más
de 1600 personas se movilizaron dentro
de Nicaragua para poder documentar y
observar este proceso electoral nosotros
registramos una abstencionismo del
82.7% hasta el momento el oficialismo no
ha dado información de los porcentajes
de participación sin embargo han hecho
grandes esfuerzos para simular mayores
niveles de participación ahora también
se reportó por ejemplo el arresto de
personas previo al proceso electoral Con
qué otras situaciones se han encontrado
o se encontraron
actualmente existen 219 personas
detenidas solo en la semana de
elecciones hemos registrado Más de 19
tensiones adicionales Además de eso
hemos visto cómo han movilizado a
fuerzas policiales y para policiales
para perseguir hostigar también han
amenazado de manera violenta a los
pobladores que intentaban defender sus
territorios diciéndoles que no
celebraron a votar y si no iban a ser
detenido o sus bienes destruidos y por
ejemplo que irregularidades pudieron
encontrar durante el monitoreo del
proceso electoral la principal
irregularidad ha sido la estrategia de
coacción del voto todos los trabajadores
del Estado fueron hostigados y
presionados para acudir a votar persona
a persona estuvieron siendo seguidos
vigilados tenían que mandar una foto de
ellos de su familias una foto de el dedo
que que simulaba que ya habían votado en
algunos casos incluso les manda los
piden una foto de la boleta con sus
nombres adentro esto porque no no logra
el consejo supremo electoral despertar
la suficiente confianza para que la
ciudadanía participe libremente sino que
tienen que recurrir a esta estrategia
las principales víctimas han sido los
trabajadores del Estado y su familia
pero también se han reportado estas
mismas estrategias sobre estudiantes de
universidades públicas o sobre pequeños
y medianos comerciantes que han sido
visitados por la autoridades locales
para decirles que si no acuden a votar y
van a perder en su permiso de operación
señora Oye una opinión generalizada
entre voces opositoras es que a estos
comercios no se les puede llamar
elecciones qué cree usted
definitivamente este proceso no cumple
con la garantía democráticas no se
pueden considerar una elecciones libres
transparentes todo eso que está que los
tratados internacionales le exigen a los
Estados por el contrario Este ha sido un
proceso que únicamente ha servido para
justificar el reembolso Millonario de
más de 13 millones de dólares que van a
reclamar los partidos después de este
proceso la autoridad electoral está
totalmente controlada por el poder
ejecutivo la ciudadanía no puede votar
libremente no se respeta el voto secreto
tampoco pueden participar no hay
competencia electoral porque no pueden
participar ni los candidatos ni los
partidos que la ciudadanía desea los
candidatos son detenidos o son agredidos
actualmente siete precandidatos a la
presidencia detenidos desde hace más de
un año y los partidos que intentan
disputar el poder han perdido sus
personerías jurídica por tanto este
todos los elementos que podrían
legitimar un proceso creíble e íntegro
en Nicaragua están totalmente
conculcados